welcome back to another edition of The
Gadget Lab I'm my polka Lori and I am at
the Baldwin and you've got BAM new
kindle kindle fire HD Roberta was down
in Los Angeles last week at the launch
event he saw mr. Jeff Bezos in person I
did and he showed off that new device he
did she often new device and if you are
the owner or if you've ever used an old
kindle this is hardware wise just brand
new really here's the the old heavy
clunky brick careful doll you can see
this is a thinner it's a little bit its
larger than the old kindle but it is
other than that it is a i'm saying it's
just a better device all around you know
one of the problems I had with this
Kindles the buttons on the bottom just
like a regular kindle but when i would
do this i would hit the button or I put
it in my pocket this has a recessed
buttons up here on the top so the home
button is recessed so you don't actually
tap it unless you find it and finally
physical volume physical volume buttons
physical volume that's good so your
listen the condom style and someone
comes in the room and you're a little
bit in bears altimeter net I don't know
why it would be embarrassed about
watching that video so we should also
talk about like what it's got on the
inside it has a new processor has a new
Texas Instruments dual-core 1.5
gigahertz processor noticeably faster
notice Lee noticeably just like when
you're flipping through the home screen
you're flipping through books you're
doing searches you're scrolling web
pages everything is improved the browser
i think is better oh it has a fully
skinned you I that's built on top of
Google Android so it's a it's ICS
android 4.0 is
what it would 2.3 on the old kindle fire
the new kindle fire HD and that they
also the other kindle fire that is
available ICS so this is the same price
as the old one the deal one used to be
it's two hundred two hundred dollars for
the 7-inch kindle fire HD the the kindle
fire that they just the regular kindle
fire that they've updated it is 160 okay
so if you're looking to get in on the
cheap you can get that one but we would
probably not recommend you do that
because this is a much better device and
it's better screen it has better
processor it's high def it's it's got a
much better operating system on in yeah
i think i'm a lot of people kind of ding
the king the first kindle for its kind
of sluggishness and they had some
updates that came out that they kind of
fixed that but this just right off the
bat we usually he makes these noises
when every fiddles with any device
really i do i make the noises regardless
we in the car by myself driving there's
also some some real interesting
technology going on in the inside for
doing things like improving band width
it has to Wi-Fi antennas to Wi-Fi
antennas it's using this thing called
mimo this technology and it uses both
antennas to to optimize your Wi-Fi
experience you know they were amazon was
really big Michael we got it this is
better than everyone else's Wi-Fi so
haven't had long enough to chest that
out yet but um everything loads faster
yeah everything loads faster the little
bar doesn't say on the screen as long so
it also has bluetooth connectivity it
has an HD camera in the front it has an
hdmi port out so you can throw the image
to a big screen TV things like that one
cool feature that I like x-ray for
movies so if you're watching a movie you
can just like pause it and you can go
into it pops up basically data that it's
pulling from IMDb and it shows you who's
in the movie you know you can read the
trivia behind the movie so basically if
you're familiar with x-ray for books
which gives you sort of like an index
view of
characters and author BIOS and things
like that this is the same thing for
videos but what are you that is this
which is the other two hundred dollar
tablet which is the next seven which
we've had since June so I think a lot of
people are trying to decide between
buying one of these or buying one of
those we should mention that you know a
lot of what you can do on the Kindle
Fire you can do on this but there are
very amazon specific features that you
don't get on any other tablets things
like x-ray and things like that the two
antennas you know what's the Dolby
speakers in the back right yes there's a
stripe I like this stripe by the way
stereo speakers tuned by Dolby so you
know this it's kind of strikes me as a
little bit of marketing BS because we
were just listening to the sound coming
out of it it doesn't sound any better to
my ears any better or any worse than
like pretty much every other tablet and
phone that's out there that doesn't it
together yeah I mean you put headphones
into it if you really want to listen to
sound or you know you just have the
tinny sound sitting around or you cook
it up to your jam box or whatever and
this is Bluetooth so you can bluetooth
so you can put it to your jam box or
external keyboard you kept in a keyboard
and actually type away so if you're if
you're that type of tablet user who uses
it as an actual writing device yeah so
it's those I think it's those few things
that have made it into a full-featured
tablet there's still the question of how
well you're going to be able to run apps
on this look if you want to go to
Amazon's app store and buy something and
install it is going to run the same
that's something that we're currently
testing and you can read Robbie's full
review of the kindle fire HD on wire
calm right now thanks for joining us and
we'll see you next time on the gadget
lab
you